E aí
[Aplausos]
As Visões de Marcos 2020 São Paulo
Brooklin recebi algumas ligações de
clientes cancelando treinamentos
presenciais era o começo da pandemia os
maiores projetos da empresa de
treinamento e desenvolvimento que
aconteceu durante 2 anos era uma trilha
com centenas de pessoas
cancelada
difícil mas compreensível ninguém sabia
o que fazer e sinceramente naquele
momento eu também não liguei para
pessoas de confiança muito menos elas
sabiam imaginava o que viria pela frente
faça uma pausa agora lembro como é que
você estava se sentindo quando o mundo
parou um e fomos obrigados a ficar em
casa lembrou muitas dúvidas surgiram
Será que vou perder meu emprego Será que
isso vai acabar logo
no passado choque veio a aceitação e com
muitas conversas estando perto de
parceiros clientes eu fiz o que eu mais
sei fazer me movimentei troquei repensei
e fala rápida adaptei tudo que eu tinha
de conteúdo para o formato online além
de criar novos voltados para a realidade
e necessidades daquele momento em dias
segunda pausa a cultura brasileira era
muito resistente a treinamentos online
sabendo disso. Era com o teu sucesso que
temos em nossos treinamentos presenciais
no formato online
como em um momento de alto nível de
estresse nossa equipe eu inclusive
poderia se a palavra que apoia que
desperta o que tem de melhor no ser
humano É sim exame desafio pessoas
entravam com a câmera fechada e mal
falava Imagina você falar para ver que
não quer te ouvir imaginou sensação ruim
não é mesmo Afinal o que fazer diante
desse cenário eu tô aqui para
compartilhar com você nove ações que
utilizei para falar de um jeito
interessante
sem perder a minha autenticidade a minha
Essência como dizem sem ser fake porque
se antes no presencial a gente precisava
Teoricamente fazer algo diferente a cada
7 minutos para reter a atenção do outro
agora pela minha experiência era pelo
menos a cada dois minutos não se trata
só de falar bem de ter uma fala Atrativa
claro que isso é muito importante mas se
trata de criar sintonia com e sendo ele
uma pessoa numa reunião ou uma plateia
de dezenas ou centenas de pessoas não
importa o tamanho a primeira coisa que
você precisa fazer é ser natural parece
que encher mas é importante você buscar
o seu melhor jeito de falar sem tentar
parecer ser outra pessoa não é fácil ser
natural falar do jeito para câmera
colocando os meus pensamentos me fez
perceber que depois de alguns minutos as
pessoas ligavam a câmera e se conectavam
de alguma forma o segundo é usar o
storytelling
uma narrativa que mobilize as pessoas
para que façam ou se convençam do seu
objetivo uma história de fato relevante
a sua urgência que consiga reter a
atenção do interruptor esteja ele onde
estiver e que de preferência
e fica em sua memória e aquilo inclui a
assertividade porque nada é pior do que
uma apresentação tem a dados em
informações repetidas ou irrelevante o
terceiro as perguntas retóricas isso
mesmo perguntas que eu não esperava em
uma resposta se alguém respondesse ótimo
eu fazer uma pergunta e uma pausa de 2 a
3 segundos na sequência por exemplo eu
vou dizer agora a comunicação é uma
competição aqui é importante Estudos
comprovam que ou poderia dizer porque a
comunicação é uma competência
tãoimportante
Estudos comprovam que o próximo o
contato visual com a câmera olhar para o
foco ocular do seu computador era
estranho no começo mas eu treinei tanto
a ponto de colocar um colchete perto do
foco para não esquecer hoje Onde tem um
aí eu procuro por ela eu preciso olhar
para você me conectar quando for pensar
no que falar evite olhar para cima
continue olhando para a câmera o quinto
humor levemente dos seus direitos sem
forçar porque uma piada errada pode
acabar com o clima ou seja sua
vulnerabilidade Afinal Todos estavam
oneraveis somos oneraveis compartilhar
minhas dificuldades ou simplesmente o
que eu pensava me fez conectar ainda
mais com as pessoas
o elemento seguinte são os meus
preferidos a alternância de velocidade
com a pausa vou mostrar na prática como
funciona
Olá você sabia que a comunicação é o
principal esquerdo profissional do
Futuro seguido pelas habilidades de
resolução de problemas
adaptabilidade e agilidade agora se você
sabia que a comunicação é o principal
skin do profissional do Futuro seguido
pelas habilidades de resolução de
problemas de adaptabilidade e agilidade
que você percebe aqui o quanto a
entonação muda a
interpretação do texto EA pausa que é
tão Sagrada promocional Harmonia clareza
e movimento nos seus cursos e
principalmente te ajuda a evitar os
famosos vícios de linguagem a oitava são
é uma estratégia para todos os momentos
não tenha calma você é um canal de
comunicação sem parece simples mas é
fundamental manter a calma e seguir em
frente com que foi programado ou Ah tá
Seja sempre muito Atento e Presidente
apresente os slides com clareza e
naturalidade
pratique a escuta ativa EA empatia não
deixe que nada interfira na sua
capacidade de comunicação nem modifique
a sua postura fala e tom de voz e por
último o que eu mais aprecio a leveza EA
simpatia leveza para lidar com
previsível com a tristeza das pessoas
com medo e até com raiva
aos seus leads conosco e com as pessoas
nos afastamos do sentimento de culpa ou
vergonha e aí nossa capacidade de
improviso aflora a gente cria coragem
força e mais do que tudo cria sintonia
com as pessoas se trata de Jesus conexão
não importa onde estejamos seja no
presidencial seja aqui falando para
vocês que e agora quando eu me conecto
consigo influenciar ajudar me aceito e
aceito o outro e o mais legal se torna
divertido e prazeroso e eu já seguro que
deu certo eu não imaginava mas eu tive
uma chuva de demandas como consequência
feedback de transformação recheado de
agradecimentos no final do ano foram
mais de 15 mil pessoas sensibilizadas e
transformadas de Inteligência Emocional
comunicação construção de jeans até como
liderar remotamente Pense nisso como
você pode se conectar não importa de
onde você esteja seja assertivo e
atrativo se adapte do seu público na
forma de falar no conteúdo e no time o
time de perceber o Outro para vocês
terem ideia eu cheguei em ambientes
online pois durante 30 minutos as
pessoas não falavam quase nada mo o
Lagos já iniciada com a pergunta sobre
as expectativas para o treinamento e
ouvir o silêncio alguém que empate zava
e dizia simplesmente
aprendizado Confesso que quando tinha
alguém que falava algo Eu vibrava por
dentro agora olha que interessante em
outras turmas os primeiros minutos eles
estava favo eu tinha que de novo fazer o
que adaptar o conteúdo a minha forma de
falar eu comecei a pegar muito gosto em
me adaptar e de tanto fazer isso fazia a
cada vez mais rápido a minha habilidade
de perceber em poucos meses cresceu
exponencialmente
Este é o meu convite para vocês
empathize Connect a comunicação muda a
vida das pessoas mudou a minha e o
espero que mude a sua
E aí